beautiful wednesday out there look at
all those gorgeous blue skies
temperatures close to 70 degrees most
neighborhoods have dropped into the 60s
that air is oh so dry we don't have much
in the way of winds
we've got some hotter days coming as we
get through the latter half of the week
but then the winds come back for the
weekend and that will drop temperatures
back to the 80s by sunday
again set your watering schedule to the
early morning or the late night
daytime watering is not allowed between
11am and 7pm because of these
hotter days that can often crop up in
may and we're going to get those here
over the next couple of days
thanks to this ridge of high pressure
that's rebuilding over the west and the
southwest
we're looking at 94 today winds have
turned mainly to the south southeast and
they'll be very light today
more heat for the thursday friday for
the end of the week
upper 90s again we've seen a couple of
days like that here and there
and then they'll get squashed thanks to
some more wind from the pacific
northwest
cooler wind drops us to the mid 80s on
sunday but really just for a day
low 90s back by monday and we're staying
very very dry